regarde bien autour de
toi trouve des idées où tu vas faire de l'endroit
une fois qu'il sera à toi
Gardien je le prononce mon pote je jure
Cody je les exhorte à te trouver je leur ai dit que
tu devrais être le seul à exploiter explique
ce
qu'ils'  tu nous emmèneras vers eux non tu nous emmèneras
vers eux oh tu finiras comme ton
ami en cage tu penses que tu
te demandes ce que les enfants aident c'est plus
familier nous n'essayons pas d'être effrayants
Bruner nous essayons de protéger notre
les gens nos familles si vous nous aidez je
vous donne mon serment vous aurez votre
liberté oh c'est bon de voir des arbres
contre la neige même de loin
rappelez-vous quand nous suivions le bœuf de sang à
travers la fenêtre de givre c'était toujours de la
viande toujours la vie tu ne le fais pas  pense que c'est
étrange que nous ayons perdu notre maison quand l'
or est arrivé au pouvoir ou ne peut pas tuer
un monde ou un temps êtes-vous sûr que
regarder autour de vous fait alors pour vous rappeler
ou quelque chose partout où l'or fonctionne c'est
magique la terre meurt
si notre peuple doit faire un  la maison ici mon
ami continue doit  être arrêté
nous ne sommes pas assez puissants pour
vaincre ce que les humains aident nous pourrions apporter